[Musique]
on dit souvent que la pomme ne tombe pas
loin de là c'est peut-être ce qui
explique le sens des affaires qui anime
trois jeunes fils d'agriculteurs à
Sainte-Croix de lobinière dans chaudière
à palaches ils ont démarré leur propre
petite entreprise qu'il gère comme des
grands
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous allez prendre encore de l'expansion
peut-être un peu mais pas autant
[Musique]
graissé aux légumes du poulet de grains
l'entreprise de nos garçons Émile Victor
et Joseph produisent des cocos
[Musique]
toujours les œufs à un temps que la
viande dans le fond c'est le service
qu'on a fait aux garçons
il va jamais pleurer et puis c'est une
zone qui s'en occupe c'est à nous c'est
notre entreprise
[Musique]
de ça ça doit être encore les parents
qui sont prises mais non je peux vous
l'annoncer j'ai déjà assez de temps à
faire notre poulailler c'est juste
je change pas les litières je fais pas
le remplissage dos ni de mouleuse c'est
eux qu'il faut qu'il m'avertissent qu'il
y a plus de moulu
[Rires]
quand on a chez les poules moi je vous
ai prêté l'argent il nous devait environ
180 dollars je me rappelle de Victor qui
a trouvé ça très difficile puis je me
rappelle le soir même qui est venu me
voir puis il me dit papa ils ont
remboursera jamais tout ça puis au fil
et les poules se sont mis à prendre un
peu plus et qui vendent un peu plus
d'oeufs plus qu'un vu le montant
descendre on voyait son sourire même
voir le soir puis dire allez on va
l'avoir on va réussir
[Musique]
ça rapporte environ par année on se fait
1500 chaque environ
au début est-ce que tu comprenais
comment ça fonctionne les finances et
tout ça non non
[Musique]
mais la dette à chaque fois qu'il y a de
l'argent
pour moi c'est une belle réussite parce
qu'il voit le stress que nous on peut
vivre comme entrepreneur agricole
à leur échelle
pour les garçons je vois ça comme un
laboratoire entrepreneurial comment
gérer une entreprise les revenus les
dépenses le soin des animaux c'est de
voir si au quotidien c'est quelque chose
qui apprécie
[Musique]
ment
autour de la gestion des tranches trouve
tes frères c'est sûr que ça arrive mais
c'est pas des gros chican va être chaud
il y a un tournoi dans la semaine puis
moi je l'ai dit vendredi ou dimanche
c'était bon tout mais là finalement vu
que tu étais allé en tournoi de hockey
je l'ai fait deux fois tu sais c'est des
petites discussions qui vont ils vont tu
sais je pense que la beauté d'avoir leur
entreprise c'est qu'ils ont pas le choix
de trouver une solution
on arrive toujours à une conclusion mais
[Musique]
c'est ce que j'aime de leur approche de
l'entreprise c'est qu'il réussisse à
comprendre la réalité qui les entoure
les garçons secondaires commencent plus
tard c'est eux qui font le train le
matin et Joseph fini plutôt le soir
c'est lui qui fait le train du soir
qu'est-ce que tu aimes le moins faire
c'est l'hiver c'est l'eau parce que
[Musique]
ici là il boivent là-dedans puis souvent
il reste de l'eau faut que ça gêne
quand je dis tournevis puis il essaie
d'enlever la glace
on va mettre de l'eau
puis construire des nouveaux couvoirs
tous les abreuvoirs chauffants c'est lui
qui a magasiné vraiment comme un intérêt
plus au niveau de des soins là des
animaux puis j'ai peut-être
[Musique]
il y en a qui peuvent mourir
est-ce
que on y arrive quand arrive dans le
poulailler
parce que toutes les poules qui
attendent
j'ai pas vraiment d'enfants que j'aime
pas faire
Joseph c'est celui qui aime beaucoup le
volet service à clientèle et vente de
produits
[Musique]
on a donné non non mon préféré du chef
parce que
Isabelle coucou
[Musique]
c'est la plus grosse pierre
toutes nos poules qu'on a donné des
dents il meurt puis quand on donne un
nom on dirait qu'on s'attache plus à eux
puis c'est plus difficile de quitter que
les autres
il faut être ça fait des grosses
journées ils peuvent arriver fatigués
et réflexions je me fais souvent est-ce
que c'est trop mais des fois je me
demande si comment faire est-ce que
c'est de façon récurrente comme ça ça
peut devenir un irritant
je pense c'est une façon aussi de comme
un pasteur depuis
maintenant je me suis rendu compte que
son grosses trop c'est beaucoup plus de
responsabilités
[Musique]
de savoir si
les
attire un peu peut-être un jour être la
relève de la nôtre je le sais pas
je pense que c'est le temps qui va nous
le dire qu'est-ce que tu vas faire plus
tard dans la vie
c'est une bonne question
[Musique]